we make assumptions about people all the
time
it's not necessarily a bad thing but how
often are we actually right about the
assumptions we make
and how often are we right about the
assumptions other people make about us
to find out we decided to put someone in
the hot seat and have 100 strangers rate
them one to 100 based on various levels
of first impression
in doing so we would hopefully be able
to see how different ways of
communicating could drastically change
the way we perceive others
welcome to one to one hundred
hi my name is julia and i'm 20. what
would you rate yourself
average too good like kind of in between
seven seven and a half
a seventy or seventy five yeah
this first group of people will only be
able to look at you
kind of nervous i've never like been
rated
so
um could she show her ears
okay cool
she was like a very busy girl for me
like
100 is like people who could be a like a
model she's flawless
and i was like well you know i can't
just go on looks i got to look at other
stuff
and this is the most shallow thing i
doctor five points because she had some
wall art
in the background i don't know if that's
my vibe
she wasn't really my type she just
looked like a plain
regular type of person
[Applause]
that was crazy it was weird it kind of
like people were like looking at me i've
never kind of experienced
being like on like a display like that i
guess i don't know
[Music]
well first off julie is giving me
fashion
fun and quirkiness and i'm loving it
she's absolutely stunning
one of the most beautiful people you
could have chosen
she's super pretty and she's also like
not afraid to be yourself
and she also sounds like really funny
like i just listened to a part of one of
her videos
and she was telling like a funny story
and that just made her even more pretty
like i'm gonna cry they're so nice
obviously she's very attractive
but like i see some of her posts where
she's advocating for black lives matters
i'm privileged i will never understand
what it's like to be black
that's what's most important to me sort
of is that sometimes people can
look extremely beautiful or attractive
until they open their mouths
it's a brave thing to do especially
because you would see backlash and
they're like pretty too it just makes
it like that much better i did like my
own
special rating between 1 and 100 1 in 50
how attractive she was
obviously i gave her a 50 because she's
beautiful the rest was like bonus points
10 points for having a cool pose ten
more points for you know
talking about black lives matter
everybody else was saying that she was
beautiful
i don't know i didn't really find her
attractive or anything it's not the type
of girl i'd usually like go for
so we can speak about your score um what
about her
instagram led to you giving that score
um
i did not realize that it was one to one
hundred
you thought it was a scale out of ten
yeah especially by
societal standards she's incredibly
attractive but i'm
not too fond of like perfection
[Applause]
there's people are so nice i was able to
cry they're so sweet
i love how they were like really putting
the importance on not just like the
outside but like on the inside they're
so sweet so kind
we are gonna head over to the next
section now which is the phone call okay
[Music]
hi julia oh hey hi how are you where are
you from
uh so i'm from vancouver how cool don't
they don't y'all have like a maple syrup
hey oh my god i love your energy i
loved it i'm here to have a good time by
like hearing your voice i'm trying to
guess how old you are
i'm i wonder what about it like makes us
think that i talk really fast i've been
told yeah i love this like i don't know
how i always just blabber and i hate it
but like that's just me
i think canadian bacon like is that it's
ham but then why is it like cocaine
bacon it's so misleading like is that
actually from canada too
i have no idea i'm a pescetarian so okay
amazing so where are you from i am from
mississippi
oh my gosh okay what do you do so i'm
like a model and like a
musician and a student so i kind of like
them all over the place so i was in new
york
then i was in la i went to turkey then i
went to india
um i just recently graduated unemployed
currently but
well the world we're all unemployed at
some point i suppose
yeah i think so definitely
um what else favorite food
favorite food um i'm not really picky
any hobbies
oh man well i'm taking five classes
right now so i don't
what are you doing to uh make the world
a better place
hmm i'm a christian so like i believe
that like
being a light in the world like wherever
i go just holding the door open or
smiling that could change someone's
whole life
oh yeah that's awesome hey man but hey
man i
i can already tell even without without
no face cams
yo great personality that's what all
right that's two minutes
oh seriously i don't know i felt that
she was just a really down to earth
person but in that two minutes i mean i
wasn't able to see any of her flaws
i'm gay so like her voice wasn't gonna
do anything for me in that way like a 52
off of someone's voice in a two-minute
conversation to me is like pretty high
um obviously she seemed like a really
nice approachable person
but without seeing someone i can only
assume really that she falls somewhere
around the normal curve
you know i enjoy talking to her so
that's why she scored more than the 50th
[Applause]
percentile
[Applause]
[Applause]
my like instinct tells me that was
probably the lowest but i could be wrong
but that's kind of like where i'm i'm
thinking i am a little insecure in how i
talk i just hate listening to myself
talk and i talk really fast
and sometimes i like mess up my words
and that kind of stuff so i guess i can
be kind of like self-conscious about
that
i talk a lot
[Music]
this one videos on so you can just stay
on camera okay
hey how are you okay oh this is an
actual person
yeah oh yeah i'm a person oh god hi i'm
julia
hi there i'm from spain i think you
maybe can notice it with the accent yeah
i love your eye
that's a beautiful accent what's your
sign
aries oh fire queen
i'm a virgo but i'm a sagittarius moon
um any hobbies
um all i do is study i'm gonna be a
pre-med student over there i'm part of a
dance team um i'm a singer or a
songwriter what about you
so can you play me a song really quick
um can i
i can't even see it
[Music]
you look so beautiful by the way i love
your hair dress
like your short hair i wish i could pull
it off i cannot but like girl
you could work it
[Laughter]
so what kind of doctor or like medical
profession do you want to be i'm
thinking about
uh being a cardiothoracic surgeon a
neurological
surgeon or both preferably alrighty
that's two minutes she is very pretty
so and you know she uh asked me about
myself like i honestly think that was a
really sweet aspect of
her making me feel very good
so that's also a plus she was really
nice and
i think what boosted up the score more
was that she was interested
in like my dance team and um when
i mentioned k-pop
[Applause]
i felt a little more comfortable i think
because i talk with my hands and i
use gestures and like facial expressions
um so i feel like maybe
it went a little better because i could
kind of like be you know show
like expressions and all that kind of
stuff thinking back to every section
and how you felt it went if you can
guess the
average score within three points of it
then you win a hundred dollars what
okay let me just i'm gonna go
[Music]
83.
oh really are you serious
scoring someone from one to 100
obviously that's really hard to do
especially if you can't see the person
i feel disgusting doing this just so you
know this is against everything i stand
for
but i'm here i'm i'm in a committed
relationship like i was like this is
what i gave her
and she was like what i was like no no i
docked her five points for wallace
so the average for that round was 86.
oh shoot oh my gosh
well i'm just a savage man i feel bad
but
i mean it is i would actually have to
get to know the person for that person
to be
like more attractive to me
attractiveness is really
subjective i think ultimately these
numbers are kind of just numbers
and it really just matters like how you
feel about yourself and how you portray
yourself
and i think the other thing is that you
know when we're evaluating people we're
always afraid of offending them
but you know ultimately i think it's
important to
be pragmatic and and to score how you
feel they should be scored
overall it was so fun and interesting to
kind of get to interact with these
people and see how they
how they saw me because i've always like
wondered like what do i look like from
somebody else's perspective
if we can meet ourselves from somebody
else's eyes that'll be so cool but also
not putting too much stress on that
because
i can't change that i'm gonna keep being
me